In this lesson, we're going to learn about this, our brain. And how the
different areas of the brain are responsible for different things. And how our
brain makes us uniquely human. We're also going to learn about the nervous
system and neurotransmitters, such a dopamine or serotonin. And how they all
come together to help us do the amazing things that humans can do.
&gt;&gt; Everything about who we are. What we think, what we imagine, what we dream and
even who we like is a function of our brain and it's activity. Damage to the
brain can have some devastating consequences. Too much of some
neurotransmitters can cause problems, too few of some can cause problems as
well. In this lesson we're going to learn about the delicate balance of the
brain and its activity. And it's important important for you to master this
material, because we will be discussing the brain throughout the remainder of
the course.
&gt;&gt; So Susan's right. Now let's start with the basics. Many people know that we
inherit genetic information from our parents and this determines things like
hair or eye color. But genetics aren't set in stone. Now the environment can
change the expression of our genetics. Now to talk more about how our genetics
makes us who we are today, I want to bring in Matt, our genetics expert here at
Udacity.